how's your sexual misconduct had a
devastating impact on your career a
touchpoints career rehabilitation center
we can help reshape your disgusting
behavior into a great new career using
therapy job training and genital
tasering once rehabilitation is complete
our patients are placed in new careers
where the impulse to touch and fondle
can make a positive difference as a
congressman there was some confusion
about my impromptu massage sessions and
friendly spankings and I was asked to
resign but now I've found a new life as
a pizza chef I'm learning new skills and
I'm finally putting my gifts to good use
for my career I occasionally thank my
subordinates for a job well done with a
friendly open mouth kiss
these are different times I had to go
touchpoints helped to place me in a new
career stress testing CPR dummies well
back at K BLS news I get it all weather
sports news rubbing squeezing women's
shoe sniffing they meet tune me the hell
out of there really fast now I've got a
great new job in retail where I get to
have sex with department store mannequin
in those mannequins
touchpoints career rehabilitation center
if this doesn't work there's always
castration
you know here's a little bit of a
follow-up one of touch points former
clients is actually working on our show
he's a former advertising executive now
he's our newest video playback engineer
and congrats and great work Kevin thanks
Conan I love my new job
[Music]
[Applause]